and that group will face the
right-hander
26-year-old tony gonzalen who is from
california
he has an era of just under 10. but
he's made the one start looked pretty
good now brandon lowe
swinging a drive hit towards left center
field giving chase's taylor
all the way back to the wall it's gone
a first inning homer for brandon lau
one nothing second home run of the
postseason for brandon
and i really really like the fact that
it went out toward left center field
that means
he stayed on the baseball a little bit
longer and shows the strength that he
has
when he does make contact and that ball
got small in a hurry blake snell 27 year
old left-hander from seattle year two of
a five-year deal
and he signed that deal coming off the
cy young award-winning season
bets and seeger in the postseason they
have been
leaking swung on and missed
and the strikeout starts the night for
snell
this is the disappearing slider seeger
flies down two quick outs for blake snow
on the first
that is strike three called on the
outside portion and a one two three
inning
on 10 pitches we find out and at the end
of one
it's raise one conjures nothing dylan
floro
is now on in relief the dodgers already
have the infield in
right-handed hitting willia thomas
ground ball to short
seeger comes home and margaux is out
from
arlington to dallas gunned down by
seeger with the infield in
a big out and there's two gone well he
was going on contact over the dodgers
really playing a shift three-minute left
side of the infield a little surprising
he was going
on balls hit to that side of the infield
versus
hit to the right field side the dodgers
two free passes
here in the second pk in the fifth
inning last night a pinch hit
single drove in a row swinging a mess he
struck him out
a three-pitch strikeout of pk hernandez
and blake snell walks two
and strikes out two in the inning to
keep the rays in front that's retired
there's two out
the 2-2 on the way got him swinging a
miss at
a beautiful curve ball and folks blake
snell's got it going on
right now he's got six strikeouts
through three innings
and the rays have two on with two outs
and joey wendell coming up swinging a
drive to the gap in right center
on the run the right fielder betsy can't
get in it's going to go all the way to
the wall
troy will score here comes margot flying
around third
he will score as well on a two-run
double by joey wendell
it's three-nothing rays this pitch comes
off the side of his hand see the circle
seat did not turn at all that's just
sitting right there in the middle of the
plate
may be the biggest hit so far in this
postseason when you think about
what they weren't able to do that is
going to add to their confidence there's
two out nobody on in the fourth
will smith coming up 3-2 pitch and
that's eight strikeouts for blake snell
a dominant start by the former cy young
award winner
he is not allowed to hit through four
wow
the required post season until his first
inning home run
he hit 14 during the regular year
swinging a fly ball well hit into that
field going back as taylor
all the way back towards the wall it's
gone
a two-round homer for brandon lau his
second of the night
and the rays have a five nothing lead
another oppo
taco if you will for brandon lau
stand on the baseball again and just
they had that one extra biscuit for
breakfast this time off the top of the
wall out there the yellow padding and
into the seats
a two-out walk constitutes a rally for
the dodgers tonight
now chris taylor swings and there's a
fly ball to right field
heading on back to the wall and gone a
home run
and well margot ran out of room and
taylor's running around the bases
the dodgers are on the board there goes
the no hitter
there goes the shutout ray's lead over
the dodgers is now
5-2 now the race have troy at third
margot first nobody out
wendell also popped to medium center his
only timeout here's a chance for the
race
swinging a line drive to the gap in left
center handing over as taylor makes the
catch on the run
joy tags hence for home he will score
and the rays have a 6-2 lead
will smith is struck out twice and the
raise they lead at 6-2
will smith with a fly ball to left field
well hit no four-man outfield's going to
defend that it's a home run
will smith with his second home run of
the post
season it is six to three tell you what
is the offense the dodgers have been
able to exhibit during the season and
also
during the postseason this game is a
long way from being over
seeger will lead it off facing a shift
on the right side of the infield
and there's a fly ball into center field
keermeyer going back to the wall and
it's gone the home run
corey seeger with his seventh home run
of the post
season the dodgers move to within two
it's a race six in the dodgers four
there are two men out one run in and one
man on it'll be ballinger last year's
mvp in the national league
strike three call 95 right down the
middle
he caught bellinger looking and the
dodgers are
put away here in the eighth so the
dodgers are down to their final out
castillo delivered check swing the
appeal
the race win straight three said chris
guccione at first
and the rays have evened up the 2020
world series